Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that
over deliver. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello! Hi there!
Hi! Ooh, we have some special guests today. We do. This is the most we have some special guests today. We do. This is the most we've ever talked on the podcast as a group. You've never had five people. No. Correct.
Angela, do you want to tell everybody what's happening? I sure do. We have a super fun episode today because we are doing a crossover with Pod Meets World. We have Ryder, Danielle, and Will from Boy Meets World. We each got to watch an episode of each other's show. Yes. Yes.
OK, Jenna, why don't you share with everyone how this episode came about? OK, well, Ryder and I know each other. Yeah. That's how this came about. Yeah. How do you guys know each other? Yes.
We have a mutual friend in Natalie's Z. Party's at her house, right? How far you guys go back? So Travis Schult is friends with my husband Lee. Okay, so it's Travis. Okay, okay. Travis, who is married to Natalie. Travis and Natalie will have a party here and there,
and you're there and I'm there. One of the first people I talked to about Pod Meets World when I was back, because I was like, how's your re-watch podcast going? And you were super helpful and you were like, do it. You'll have the best time, it's so good. And yeah, you were like one of the people that really convinced me that this was a
great idea. Oh, good. Oh, I'm so glad. Well, your podcast is super successful. They guys have an amazing community. You guys are real friends in real life like me and Angela. Yes, you do a fantastic job telling the show, telling all the scenes and what goes on behind. I think it's just such a great podcast. And I really am so curious to watch more episodes now. Truly, truly. Especially now that I know some of the things you can share with us.
Oh, yeah. A little trivia. How did we get there? Yeah. Yes, yes, because full disclosure, Angela and I had not seen an episode of Boy Meets World until this collab happened. I think similarly, Ryder, had you ever seen an episode of Boy Meets World until this collab happened. I think similarly, Ryder,
had you ever seen an episode of The Office? Yeah, I had only watched probably the first two seasons. Okay. Maybe up to three. So you had not seen the episode we picked for today then. No, no. Will has seen every episode of The Office numerous times. Oh. I'm also a little weird when it comes to TV,
so if I see it more than once, I can recite it backwards and forwards. So I watched the episode again, you had us watch, but I didn't need to. I could have literally told you what you were wearing, usually in most of the scenes. Wow. He knew it very well.
You're like a genius person. With TV. Photographic memory on TV. Wow. Yeah, with TV. So like, if I have nothing to do and I'm bored and there's nothing around me, I shut my eyes and watch MASH. Come on. It's true. Back, with TV. So, like, if I have nothing to do and I'm bored and there's nothing around me, I shut my eyes and watch MASH.
Come on. Because you can just play that in your head. And the images are there as well as the... The images, the sound, the music, the breaks. But if he doesn't have his giant calendar in front of him, he can't remember what there is to do or whether or not something is scheduled. My wife helps, but no, I don't know. So TV, selective genius. There's a little bit of undercurrent business happening in this conversation.
They just know not to ask anymore. Be here such and such a time and she'll text my wife. They also just say, could you just take a picture of the big calendar? Because I understand that you can't care. It's a literal giant calendar. We also just say, could you just take a picture of the big calendar? Because I understand that you can't care. It's a literal giant calendar. So I'll say, because if you just had the picture of it, you'd know if you were free on the eighth. This is a really good idea. So did you take a picture of your calendar?
I think the last one I took was in April. Yeah. So I have to leave where I'm supposed to be. Otherwise they just tell me where I'm supposed to be. You guys, we are actually in your studio today. It's lovely, and there are cameras. I feel like they could make a video for you of your calendar that you would watch,
and then you would know everything. That's not a bad idea. I'd know where I'd have to be and all the stuff I had to do. Again, comes to episodes of The Office all day long, where I have to be tomorrow, anybody's guess. I feel like you could be a really good asset for office ladies. What would you like to know? I mean, they tomorrow, anybody's guess. I feel like you could be a really good asset for office ladies.
What would you like to know? I mean, I mean, we're gonna hit you up. Okay, great. I mean, yeah. Please, let me know. Be happy to. I'll walk you through it.
It's a great show. Thank you. Not to belabor this, but I am really fascinated. Does this extend as well to things you've read, books, articles? It depends on what, if it's stuck in my brain, it's forever stuck in my brain.
And I can go back and see the page, see the thing. But then again, a calculia is a very real thing. So put two numbers in front of me and my brain doesn't comprehend them. You also in school wouldn't take notes. You would just watch the teacher. I could, because if I look down to take notes. If you look down, you wouldn't.
But if he just listened and watched it. If I listened and just watched the board, then I could just see the board. No, but again, if somebody gave me a phone number or people's names, I have to meet somebody a thousand times before I remember their names. But I can see the blue shirt you're wearing. I can see the shirt you walk in on when,
fashion show, fashion show at lunch. I can see the color of the pew show. You guys should quiz him. You should ask him the shirt. Wow, if you remember a certain line or moment. Yeah, so stuff like that. It's so crazy because we just did a side-by-side. A fan wrote in and said that they think that Josh
and Stamford is wearing the same suit that Michael Scott wears on his birthday. And I had to go and look at both episodes and take a picture of each one and make a side-by-side. And it's not the same suit. No, it's not the same suit. Birthday episode is when he goes and plays hockey with the blue shirt and the blue tie. Yeah. Yeah, no, that's not. Holy cow. It's not exactly the same suit. That's not the same suit. No, it's not the same suit. Birthday episode is when he goes and plays hockey with the blue shirt and the blue tie.
Yeah. Yeah, no, that's not. Holy cow. It's not exactly the same suit. That's not the same suit. No, no, no. And also, which episode are you talking about with Josh from Stanford? Is this, you don't snipe in Carrington.
Oh, is it the initiation? Was it the initiation? Which is right before Diwali. A branch closing. Branch closing, oh, is when you leveraged the promotion to do another offer. That was the branch closing. Okay. So when Jen's like, I've driven something like 400 miles today.
So I'm just going to say this. That one. I think that one. Yeah. So he has a pinstripe suit on and a bright blue shirt, which is similar to Michael's birthday. He does, but it's a different, it's wider pinstripes than Michael's. And the tie is different.
The tie is different as well. Yeah. Why do I need to do side by side photos anymore? You don't. Just call Will. Just call Will. A new resource. I mean, yeah, that's not. If I ever decided to use this for evil.
We don't even want to go down that path because it'd be be pretty dangerous. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. Don't come at me, trivia night at a bar. If it was an office themed trivia night. Like I win Jeopardy most nights night at a bar. Yeah. Oh, trivia like, like. If it was an office themed trivia night. Like, I win Jeopardy most nights. Oh, wow. Yeah, I know a lot.
You have to go on Jeopardy. I know. I don't know if I'd be able to. Celebrity Jeopardy. Running in would be the weird part for me. I don't know if I'd. Oh, the buzzer. I was asked to do it one year and I freaked out.
I was like, I could lose. I'm a teen celebrity Jeopardy. I was like, I don't want to go beat Melissa Joan Harden in Jeopardy. Just make me feel bad. So yeah. All right, you guys. Pod Meets World is a fantastic rewatch podcast of the hit show Boy Meets World. It premiered on ABC in 1993.
Yeah. Oh my goodness. It ran until 2000. All three of you guys were on it. And over the course of the run, the show received numerous awards and nominations. And in 2020, Boy Meets World won online film and television Hall of Fame Award for television programs. Really?
What? When did we win? What? According to IMDb. You guys, 2020 Hall of Fame. Your show Hall of Fame Award. Wow. Why weren't we invited?
I wonder if no one sent us even a screenshot. I'd like to thank Fame Award. Wow. Why weren't we invited? No one sent us even a screenshot. I'd like to thank my parents. Exactly. Wow, that's cool. I'd like to bring up the fact that we were all five on long running hit television shows. Amazing. But there was a big difference.
Y'all were kids. Yeah. So can you tell us how old were each of you when the show started and then when it ended? I was from 12 to 19. Okay. 13 to 20. 16 to 24.
Wow. Yeah. Yep. Wow. And also filmed in front of a studio audience. Yes. Which is different. Very wonderful.
Very few episodes where we would not have an audience. Two or three, right? I think a handful. Yeah, but it was, oh God, there's nothing like show night. Yeah, so much more like theater. Yeah. Yeah. And especially when you're on a younger god, there's nothing like show night. Yeah, so much more like theater. Yeah. Yeah.
And especially when you're on a younger show, especially when we're starting to get popular, I'm putting that in quotes, because we were never really that popular when we were on. It was later we became popular, but kids would line up. So it'd be 14 and 15 year olds just screaming all night long. And it was, it's such a rush. It was really great. Yeah.
That must've been such a buzz in the room. Oh god, it was so fun. You know, our soundstage was really quiet. And you were happy if buzz in the room. Oh god. It was so fun You know our sound stage was really quiet and yeah You were happy if you saw the boom mic guy shake a little bit Yeah, like I got him. I got him. Yeah, but otherwise it was pretty quiet except for us breaking I was gonna say you must have wanted to break each other just to just to get that Do you not watch the outtakes of the office? I love when you're making each other laugh, but when the dialogue's so funny that you're making yourself laugh,
that's one of my favorite things in the world, where you can't even get through the line because they're so good. I think you're talking about Wayne Wilson. He would crack himself up all the time. All the time, all the time. Well, wait, so when we were on Pod Meets World, we were watching the Boy Meets World episode,
hair today, goon tomorrow, and today we are watching The Surplus from The Office. And speaking of bloopers, I think one of the hardest times I ever laughed in a scene was when Dwight gives Andy and Angela directions to... Oh, gosh. So many cases to hear the beehives. That's a great blooper.
Ed and I could not keep it together. I have a question. We've talked a lot about how on the office there was this real collaboration between the writers and the showrunner and the actors. How much input did you guys have into your lines or changing a line or a storyline? I know that Hair Today Goon Tomorrow was a little bit inspired by Danielle's desire to cut her hair. Yes. I see head shaking. I see head shaking.
No, it was very top down, no. It was very- When you got to improvise a little bit. I got to, especially towards the later seasons, they kind of let me do my thing. So I could improvise, I would often button scenes, but we weren't really changing our dialogue. Unless something was awful.
I had one, I grew up in a military family, and I had one where we do an episode where like you do, a magical cat sends you back to World War II. You know, oh. Like it happens. Yeah, magic cats. Magic cats. And so a lot of the stuff they had me doing
was I'm in a military uniform and being really disrespectful. And I went to our producer and said, I'm not gonna do this. And in all fairness, he went, okay, fine. And they changed it. Yeah. But we as young actors, I won't say kids,
we weren't really going up. No. In fact, they started taking things from my life more and more, like sort of, you know, sort of being my character was being inspired by writers real life. Yeah. Annoyingly so. And more and more as the show went on and without permission. Yeah. I mean, it's so interesting because of course, as an adult actor, like having input on your character, you know, is like part of the process. But as kids, we never felt we felt like being a good actor would
be, you know, and probably being told how to say with a line reading. So we were the other thing we talk about on the podcast a lot is that one of the things our executive producer was famous for is we would finish a run through and then we'd all gather for notes and the notes would sometimes be an hour and a half to two hours long of just to each of you like line by line. He'd start on page one and basically like page one, line one have notes about how everything was wrong and how we needed to do it a different way. And it's very clear you guys don't understand
the point of this episode. So let me tell you here's what's... What a fun creative environment. Yeah, it was. But at least we were children. Yeah. So it makes it better. I did hear on your podcast and I love this
that you would find ways to like sneak in a, huh, uh-huh. Yeah, yeah. So now I'm gonna be rooting for that whenever I see it. That is true that we would try to make each other laugh. Yeah, they're in jokes, but they're not in the dialogue. It's the subject. So we're like sending messages to each other with like intonations or physical moves.
Watching it back for the podcast has been so fun to see again and be like, oh my God, I remember this. Yeah. It was also stuff that the writers weren't aware we had. They were truly like inside jokes. It was probably our own little rebellion of like, watch me slip in a joke to my friend that you don't know is a joke.
Especially if you'd been told for an hour and a half how you don't get it and you're doing it wrong. I'd want to like sneak in something. Yeah. It wasn't particularly collaborative. It was fun, but it wasn't particularly collaborative. Yeah. Right.
Oh. Sorry. Is our podcast that or the yours? Is our podcast getting there? All right. All right. So I have a pivot here. OK,'t stand her. I can't stand her. I can't stand her. All right, all right, all right. So I have a, I have a pivot here. Okay, so you remember every scene
of every episode of The Office. Pretty much, yeah. Well, I thought there was a great crossover story between here today, Goon Tomorrow, and an episode from The Office. Not the one we're watching today, not Surplus, but there is a similar scene. Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. Really? We're meeting a townie. Let's see, a good-looking detective. Good-looking detective. Do you want a hint? Do you want a hint? Yes, give me one, because, yeah.
Small hint. Sofa. Sofa. Sofa. Oh, well. I'm so tickled by this. I'm so kidding. Now, I'm just trying to remember from our episode
where the sofa. Oh, yeah, OK. There it is, thank you. Yeesh, this is, I pay for that privilege. I only have one weird thing about me. I use the ladies room for number two and I have paid off. And yeah, this is, there's a couch. That's right, okay. That's right, in women's appreciation, the office episode,
the men, first of all, we find out Creed's been using the women's room and they go in there and there's a sofa and they hang out in there. And I thought it was really funny when we watched this episode, you guys were like, there's a sofa. I had the same thought.
I was like, oh my gosh. And you know what else I thought of? I have not been in very many women's restrooms with sofas. I think at least they have an in they had Nordstrom lounges. And high schools. The girls in our high school had a couch. They had a sofa? We'd go in there to smoke when the boys' room was too full.
Oh. Yeah. I have run across very few sofas. That's Kevin, like, this is the dream. Isn't the dream the girls' locker room? Normally there's girls in there, Kev. Yeah. You're still blown away, dude. I Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Very good.
Still blown away, dude. I know we talked about that you could do this, but when you really can do it, like on the spot, and it's not a bit, it's crazy to me. It's crazy. Way my brain works, yeah. All right, well, guys, this is gonna be so much fun. So much fun, yeah.
We're excited to be with you. We are gonna take a break, and when we come back, we're going to discuss the surplus. Yay! Yay! All right, everyone. Father's Day is approaching. And guess what? Macy's is your gifting destination. Let Macy's be your guide to gifting for Father's Day. I have been getting all of my holiday gifts at Macy's.com lately. It is fantastic. It's the gift
guide. All right, well, I'm not going to see my dad this Father's Day. They are going on a cruise. How great is that? Fun. And I thought about that amazing pullover that I got him for Christmas that he wears all the time. I got it at Macy's.com. So I went on the Macy's.com Father's Day gifting guide and I put in like vacation wear and I got him the coolest shorts and then kind of like, you know, they're going to the tropics. I got him like a tropical shirt for his cruise. This is stuff my dad will not buy himself. He will not buy like, you know, theme clothing. Oh, I know.
I know. Right? He's all practical. I sent it to him. He loved it. He already got it, you know, because he's going to be gone on Father's Day. So I sent it early and he's thrilled. Well, you know, for Father's Day this year, we're at a volleyball tournament.
Our son has a volleyball tournament. So that's where we're going to be all day. But we get up super early and Josh is such a coffee guy. So I'm on Macy's.com looking at their gifting guide and they have really great reasonably priced gifts too. And so if you have a coffee lover or you need exercise equipment or I mean, they just have everything in addition to clothes and all the other stuff. I got Lee's gift on Macy's.com, one of his gifts.
And I don't want to say it, but travel was like my thing in my brain this year. I got him a travel case that holds both sunglasses, eyeglasses, and wristwatches. Oh, that's great. I know. It's super cool. And I think it's something I wouldn't have thought of
if I didn't have the guide. Well, I got Josh Colon. He loves, you know, he smells good. He's a good smelling fella. He doesn't go overboard, but I love the way he smells. So I got him Hugo Boss Colon. Macy's has all that kind of stuff. Josh, don't listen, but I think it's going to smell really good on you.
So I'm getting you that for Father's Day. Let Macy's be your guide to gifting this Father's Day. Shop the Father's Day gift guide now at macy's.com slash gift guide. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you see that hilarious Saturday Night Live sketch they did about men's health and mental health where like in order to trick men into taking care of themselves, they made a medical clinic that is like a podcast, like a Dude Bro podcast. Oh my gosh, it's so funny.
But it's also because it's kind of true. Men are often reluctant to take the time to dig into their mental health. I've got a stat for you. Six million men in the US suffer from depression every year and it's often undiagnosed. So listen, if you're a man and you're feeling the weight of the world,
we would like to encourage you to talk to someone, a friend, a loved one, a therapist. Maybe you wanna give BetterHelp a try. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month
at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. All right, everybody, we're back, That's betterhelphelp.com slash office ladies. All right, everybody, we're back. And now we're gonna talk about the office episode, the surplus. This was season five, episode nine, written by Jean Stepnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, two of our favorite writers.
Writing team. And our beloved director, Paul Feig. Yes, Paul Feig. I think I've worked with Gene and Lee. Yes? I think I did a show, can't remember the name of it, but pretty sure that they wrote on it. Okay.
That is my story. Good story, bro. Hello ladies. Cool story. No. Bad teacher? No, I think it was a pilot. Okay.
Sometimes with stories. A multicam? Yes. You wanna have detail. No. OK, here's what I will say. I think it happened. I'm pretty sure I worked with Gene and Lee.
They play in several episodes, aren't they? Gene and Leo. That's right. From Vance Refrigeration. So yes, 99.9% sure we have worked together. I vote to cut that part. No, because it's true. Keep it in.
Okay. They're gonna hit you up afterwards and be like, here's the show that we did together with Will. Yeah. We'll look it up. We'll look it up. We'll Google it. Perfect.
I'm gonna give you a summary of the episode and here it is. Oscar informs Michael that they have a $4,300 budget surplus and the surplus must be spent that day or it gets returned and taken out of next year's budget. The office is then divided on what to spend it on, new chairs or a new copier. This creates tension between Jim and Pam
who are on opposing sides. Meanwhile, Andy and Angela visit Shrut Farms to discuss their wedding with Dwight, who tricks Angela into marrying him. I mean, what the heck? Michael then learns a third option for the surplus money, which is return it in exchange for a 15% bonus for himself. Mm-hmm.
Do you know? Do you know? I think, I think you know. Yes. Oh, yes. He has an Oscar surplus. Do you know? Do you think you know?
Yeah. I think you know? I think you know. I think you know. What were your overall reactions to this? Because we decided to pick quintessential episodes. And I think the thing I love about this episode so much is that it isn't a later season. And the A story is just a quirky office thing. Yes. That happens all the time.
All the time in offices. Yeah, where like the hot goss that's going around is about something as mundane as chairs versus copier. And the dynamics of- Spins everybody out of control. No one's focusing, no one's, by the way, no work is getting done in that office ever. The manure being in the kitchen, in fruit farms. And also like no one is clocking the odor.
Like people talking. And it's a big pile of shit like right next to the table. It just really made me laugh out loud. Yeah, you know what makes me laugh every time I watch this episode is when Mike Shur is most hits Ed, his head in the head. With the ball. In the background. Yes. Yeah. It cracks me up every time because I really think that Ed wasn't quite expecting it.
So every time he's like, hey. It does look like he turns around really confrontational. Like, yeah. What just happened there? Which is it's so funny. I'm somewhere in between Ryder and Will with my viewing of The Office. I'm pretty sure I have seen most seasons every episode at some point. I do not have a fraction of Will's photographic memory for them. Who does?
And wait, Ryder, had you seen this episode? No, I don't think so. Yeah, no. But it felt like a quintessential office episode. That's what I remembered the show being, like sort of, you know, like you're saying, detailed, like meaningless conflict that just blows up and gets to show people's behavior.
I thought it was hysterical. I mean, it's brilliant. It's so funny. And like the show's ability to make awful actions incredibly like, well, it's just unparalleled. You know, I feel like a lot of what your show brought was like, you know, the beginning of like cringe comedy or like, but cringe comedy usually is mean
or like people are kind of awful and you're like, oh my God, I can't believe this person said that. Whereas like every time Michael opens up his mouth, it's the funniest thing ever. And you're like, I like that guy. Yeah. He's, I mean, you don't want to, and everybody, you know, Dwight even who is sort of more on the meaner side,
you still love him. Like everybody, and the show is just so brilliant that it manages to pull that off and still have very comedic, like I was laughing out loud and I realized I have not laughed out loud, even at comedy these days. I feel like comedy these days, you're sort of like, you know, or like whatever.
You guys managed while being incredibly realistic with the performances and understated, still big laughs. Laugh out loud beats. And so I just think it's such an accomplishment and like a legendary show for that. Jenna, you saying, no, don't take it away when he's shaking his butt in the show. That was my favorite moments, yes.
You're so sweet. It was the perfect amount of all of us knowing that you are faking it, but also easily plays like you mean it in the moment. Right, when she starts to have to dance with him. He's sort of thinking, I see you like half-hearted, and I'm like, I'm gonna act, and I'm crazy perfect. Cause you see all of it, like, I guess I'm gonna dance now,
no, we're stopping good. Okay, it's like all there in that moment. It's so funny. Also you fluffing your hair with the red lip. All right, know what I gotta do here. It's on, it is so on. This episode, I'm so glad you guys picked this one. It's one of my favorites.
It has, in my opinion, the most underrated joke of any office episode. And I find it to be one of the funniest things ever said on the entire show, and it's that fast. Which one is it? It is the very beginning when Oscar is explaining to Michael about the lemonade stand and he just says in the next summer, Michael just goes, I'll be six.
That's like he's so excited. He thinks he's got the point of the whole thing. It's like now I know the math. Because he just says, I'll be six. Genius on so many levels. I remember the first time I see it, just keep reminding like, it's the perfect joke. It is the perfect joke. So it's just, oh, I just explained to me like I'm eight
and then he does, and I'll be six. Oh gosh, it is so well done. Now this is like, we talked about the Boy Meets World episode, we talked about this episode is so well balanced between the A story and the B story. It's so funny how you find heart in the office because the scene where Angela finally says to Dwight, I made a mistake.
Yeah. You've been waiting for this. I'm taking a mistake. I'm supposed to be with you. Yeah. It's a big deal. Dwight, of course, says, well, yeah, well, I know. And that's why I just tricked you into marrying me.
And you should have learned German when I told you to. Exactly. I've been telling you to take it for years. It is just, that's one of the things I love about your show is that our show, you know you're gonna get heart because the music swells. And we're telling you, you're going to get heart. Your show, you find it in beats
that you don't think are gonna exist. And it's Pam being drunk and falling off the chair at Chili's and then Jim picking her up and then Tiny Dancer slowly starting to play in the background. It's all just, it's all beautiful. So yeah, but this episode though, and then of course the ending, which is magical, the magical tag.
By the way, I didn't see that coming when he's wearing the fur coat. I thought, oh, I love that we're just going to see that he bought a fur coat. And I, the blood was just, how did they talk? Even just the fact that he bought a fur coat. And the blood was just how did they talk? Even just the fact that he had the fur coat. But also, I was blown away by the writing in that because it starts when you are asking him about his suit and you're using the suit. And that's where he throws out how much the suit costs. And so I thought that was it.
But then he brings up the Burlington Coat Factory because it makes him wanting that $600 so much better. Because if you hadn't planted the seed that he is trying to save money by getting good suits, $5, but it starts as just this you flattering him joke, then it builds to a coat at the end and all you needed to see, like I mean, the tag could have just been him like doing the interview in the coat and I was already dying.
That's what I thought. I thought, wow, of mean, the tag could have just been him, like, doing the interview in the code, and I was already dying. That's what I'm saying, that's what I thought. I thought, wow, of course, that was such a payoff, but then they even found the topper to it. Yes, yeah. One of the things I never get tired of, even in our rewatch, is Steve as Michael, when he's about to curse and they cut him off. Oh, yes.
He's like, mother, it's a curse. Always so funny. As you guys call his bluff on getting the chairs, I just loved it so much. I've always wanted to know, how much did the script stay the same from when you first got it to when you actually shot? Like how much are you ad-libbing
and just going with on the moment, and how much was actually on the page? Well, do you mean sort of from our table read to what we shot? Table read draft to shooting draft? Yes. Or shooting draft to what you see on air? Both.
Yeah, both. I would say there would be some pretty big changes between the table read draft and the shooting draft. But then the shooting draft to what you see on screen, a lot less than you would think. Whoever wrote the episode would also be on set with the director producing their episode. And they would be throwing out extra lines and ideas.
So a lot of times it wasn't an improv, but it was an alternate that the writers gave you. Likewise, though, you could go to the writers. We had the permission to go to the writers and it was a real creative collaboration. So you could go up and say, hey, I have a really great button for the scene and accounting. Will you let me know once we've got it the way you want it the way the director wants it and then can I do like my pass? Oh, that's great. Yeah. And you, we were smart enough that you didn't improvise within the scene. You know, if you did tops in the bottom, that way they can edit around, you don't mess with the storyline.
And I think a lot of little moments like that do make it in. But it was truly just a great scripted show. But I think if you went to the script and you looked at that Michael talking head that is the tag, it would be word for word. It would, OK. Like, very often. Also, they would write in ellipses. They would write in pauses.
They would write in Pam glances to camera. So like, all of that that just like seems like it's just happening, it was choreographed. Wow. And then also the idea that the camera would get to you in the middle of what you're saying, instead of landing on you perfectly. We were going to say it or that the joke was over there.
Part of the comedy came from getting to it late. So they would actually put that in the script, like whip hand to? Yeah, whip to Jim. Yeah, Jim looks to camera. Yeah, Jim's size. Okay, so those looks to camera were always looks to camera or did they get a shorthand eventually in the script
or they were just like, give us the look? Sometimes you could tag the camera, like if you wanted, but they didn't want everyone looking down the barrel of the camera all the time. So, you know, like I'm not sure if it said in the camera, like, if you wanted, but they didn't want everyone looking down the barrel of the camera all the time. So, you know, like, I'm not sure if it said in the script, like, that I'm checking in with camera because I'm embarrassed that I'm, what I'm doing to Michael. Like, some of those just ended up becoming second nature,
like, you know, like, to kind of give the camera like, oh my God, I'm so, so sorry. We had A camera catching the main scene and then B camera was always roving the background. So you had to be on from the minute you were at your desk. Oh, I love that so much. And you had to be in character. It's very actory.
You have to be in character. And our B camera operator, Matt Stone, would often come up to us in the background and say, I can see your screen, log out of your email. Or he would say something like, I just saw that you did an eye roll after Pam says that line. You're in the deep background, but it was great and I caught it.
So if you want to do it again, I caught it. So that was just us staying in character. But that's how the crew was so much part of the creative process. Cause they were finding moments that weren't necessarily on the page, right, that helped tell out, you know, fill out the whole story. One of the things that we noticed about our show is that as it progressed, they started
to notice which characters really worked with other characters. So airs started to form. Did you start to notice that on your set as well? Like all of a sudden, because, you know, as the show progresses for a while, all of a sudden, you know, Pam and Angela start to have kind of an interesting dynamic. Was that something you think that was planned at the beginning, or was it they were just looking at what worked and then started to write
to the relationships they saw? Well, our writers told us that something they would do sometimes is they would get a writing assignment where they would just take a random pairing of actors, and they'd have to pitch storylines for them. Oh, that's so cool. For characters.
Genius. And there's an episode, I can't remember what the name of it is, where they all go out in pairs on sales calls. Uh-huh, oh yes, yeah. Oh, yes, so it's Jonathan and Karen. You're the mother-daughter team, you're the young firefighters.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right, and that was an episode that came out of that, they would call it the the unusual pairings. Oh, no, that was the salesman, the return. Yes. Yes. The return. Yes. I really wish we had to. I could have helped out. Yes. Can you just come sit in on a. I would be happy to. That's what it starts with.
Cassie, our producer, we're like Cassie, go go. I wait. What episode was that? Yeah. Dwight is bringing has to bring the late taxes back to New York. He misses the entire time for Angela. For Noelle. And yes, exactly. That's when your hair, the back of your hair was very-
It's like a pinwheel. Yeah, the pinwheel all the way around. Very dramatic, the way they did the back of your hair in that episode. One of my favorite, like completely undiscussed jokes is when Michael is pouring sugar into a guy's- Exactly! Is that in the script?
Will something like that always be in the script? Yes, that is in the script. That's in the show Bible for Michael Scott that he adds sugar to his diet so bad. That's what I was gonna say. Oh my God, it's like perfect. Yes, so what was great I loved about our show is like let's say that's established one time
in an early season, that it keeps finding its moment back into the show. Yeah, yeah. We got one small glimpse of it because I have all the DVDs and when you got to the dinner party, which is arguably one of the greatest, they gave you the script. The script came with the DVD. Oh, no way. So you got, it was the size of sides, but you got actually the script.
And I was, that's why I wanted to ask, because some of the stuff was right on and other stuff it was like, okay, they said, Andy harmonizes with the song, but then he kind of goes off and does his own thing. So I was just curious how much you got to play as you were doing it because it was, man, it was so good. We did get to play a lot. We did.
Most of the time, like, I feel like what you ended up seeing on screen was, it was mostly scripted. Yeah. Gotcha. But it was mostly scripted. Yeah. Gotcha. It was a very playful collaborative set. It must have been so fun. It was so fun. You talked about alternate takes that you would use. You have one of my favorites, which they didn't put in, which you say, I used to get a runner's high,
which is why now I lift. And which didn't make it into the show, which I thought should have. They were called our candy bag alts, and our writers would write, you know, so you would have one talking head, they might write 10 extras. Wow.
You would get handed those pages as you sat down, you would learn the one in the script, they would hand them to you right as you started your talking heads and you would get the scripted one. Then you'd kind of look down and do the rest. And a lot of times in talking heads, that's where you can play a little bit too. Yeah. And Greg Daniels, we asked him, like, why did you call him the candy bag? Yeah, he named him the candy bag. Yeah, so you guys here are the candy bag.
And he said, well, I knew it was a lot of extra stuff and I didn't want you guys to be mad, so I thought I'd name it something fun. It's a candy bag. So smart. It's a bag of candy. Yeah. It's like if I called him the alts.
Yeah, that would be amazing. Here's your oatmeal alts. I have 10 Alts. I have 10 Alts. Whether it's a family member, friend or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muscogee or down Toronto's bustling streets. From now until June 30th, lease a 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000. Condition
supply. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer or go to volvocars.ca for full details. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer or go to volvocars.ca for full details. So something I want to ask you guys, people always ask us, why do you think the office is so relatable? And I don't think that the answer is because everyone's worked in an office, because clearly not everyone has worked in an office. But I did work in an office and so did Angela. And I'm curious, since you guys grew up doing television, you were actors by the time you were adults. Did you ever work in an office? I've never had a real job.
Have any of you guys? I've never had a real job in my life. I worked in customer service. Okay. For Bloomingdale's. You have a very good customer service voice. Thank you. Yes, I appreciate that. Yeah, I worked in customer service. I really only got the job because I'm a good gift wrapper. Oh! Was that part of it? It was during a holiday for gift wrapping. So I actually just wanted to wrap presents. And they were like, well, it's a customer service job.
And it was like, could I just be the person in customer service who wraps the presents? And the truth was, I did get to wrap most of the presents, but I also had to like be there to help people with their credit card bill and deal with other issues. You know, the Bloomingdale sale where you get a $25 gift card for every $200 you spend. I had to help people with that stuff.
I had that real job. Okay, so there's a very famous episode where Pam says that if you need more than three pieces of tape to wrap a present, you're doing it wrong. How many pieces of tape do you use? And I disagree with Pam as Angela Kinsey because I tape the crap out of my gifts. Like, good luck opening them. So I use double-sided tape. Oh, fancy.
Next level. So you need one to cover the back and at least two to do the perfect triangle folds on each end. Okay. So is there a way to do it with only folds on each end. Okay. So is there a way to do it with only three pieces of tape? Yes. Do you get the most bang for your buck presentation wise? No.
So can I do it? Yes. Do I do it? No. By the way, the next couple of lines after three pieces of tape are Roy then says, well, can I just use the comics from the newspaper? And you say, yeah, your mother would love that. Oh my gosh, that is nuts.
Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. You know, every holiday season, people send that to me. And I use way more than three pieces a day. I wrap a gift. And every time I give a gift to someone, I feel like they're judging me. No, no, it's just because you care more about the aesthetics.
OK. thank you. So now you guys have never worked in an office. No. And have you ever had jobs other than actor or producer? I mean, not entertainment, yeah, not entertainment, just teaching. I teach, but that's it. You teach history.
I worked one day in a motorcycle shop when I was 13. Were you on hiatus from the show or was this before the show? It was before the show. I was on Nickelodeon at the time. OK. But it was my dad. It was his client and I just bought a motorcycle and I wanted to learn more about them. So I thought this was my in. I worked one day and then that was it.
Because you quit or you got fired? Neither. It was just I think he thought, OK, I'm going to let him come in here one day. Other than a child actor, I didn't even know it was legal to work before at least the age of 15. I don't think it was, but most of the shit I did wasn't legal by the time I did it. I know, that's true. That's true. He also started smoking at 11, so. I was a heavy smoker by 11. Oh my God. He's got a weird life.
A wonderful, beautiful, weird life. I just picture you smoking on the subway going into New York for my job. I was. Yeah, that was me. Yeah, 11 to 37. 35. Actually, May 27. Coming up, we're going into New York for my job. Yeah, I was. Yeah, that was me. Yeah, 11 to 37, 35. Actually, May 27th. Coming up. Hey, anniversary.
It will be my 11 year anniversary without a cigarette. That's great. Thank you very much. Congratulations. I miss it all the time. I don't actually. But no, yeah, so I know I never had a job. Well, you know, this gets a little bit to my point,
which is that I feel like the reason why the office works is because you don't have to work in an office to know a Dwight. No, no. Or to have met your Michael. No, it's all just human behavior. It's so good. It's so relatable.
And the performances are just amazing. Yeah. And I feel like you guys changed television, because you just brought everything down a notch. Still, like I said, still managing to pull off big laughs, giant set pieces. But man, it's just so nice to see people behaving like people. You know, and like when we go back and watch our show,
as much as I'm able to say like, it was good. Like it was, you know, it's a sitcom. It's a very stylized form of rhythm and acting. And it has its benefits. Realism though, like, you know, I mean, often we would have moments of realism, but you know, the jokes were like, da-da-da-da-da, you know, you're just hitting it.
And you guys didn't have any of that, still had a musicality, still had a rhythm, but it was part of the camera. It's really remarkable and yeah. But what you were doing is really difficult, and you do it so well on the show, and I couldn't do it. In my early acting struggles and trying to land a role, I was going out for three camera because
that's what you did. That's what you did. That was the majority of shows were. And I was terrible. I was terrible. I couldn't do it and I didn't understand because I was like, it's in front of a live audience. I went to theater school. It's just theater, right? But it's not just theater. It's its own art form. It's a certain kind of style. And it is to be respected. And you can do it, Angela. Not great, lady. Not great. No, you can. Much better than me. I mean, right after the office wrapped, my agents were like, let's get you on a three camera.
And they said, do you want to do this role for Hot in Cleveland? And I was super excited. And I've told you this with Betty White, my gosh. You can't wait. I had to be the bitchy principal. This is in my wheelhouse. I just spent nine years being the bitchy principal. And I said the line and the director was like,
louder, say it louder. And then I said it louder, but then it sounded weird. And then he was like, can we get her like maybe a cane, like a cane, like she comes in like with a, and I was like, and he goes, maybe she has a hat. And Craig Ferguson was in the episode with me and we had become friends at this point. And he goes, maybe we get her a parrot and a patch.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, yeah, there you go. But they're trying to sitcom it up. They were trying to like make me more of a bigger character and I had forgotten, I didn't know how to do it. Yeah, you'd gotten so used to the volume and tone level that you guys were on. It's so different.
And I do love sketch comedy, but I think like I didn't know how to time it out with all the moving parts Well, just thank God the office came along for me because I did not thrive in the three-camera world I really tried I always thought that I was like a pretty naturally funny person and that comedy was my thing in terms of Comedy acting but I was not a fit for the three-camera style in fact the one major role that I landed was the pilot of Man with a Plan, starring Matt LeBlanc.
And I was on for many, many seasons without me. Because I was fired after the pilot. Oh, geez, yeah. Yeah. That was my big job after the office was Man with a Plan. And I just struggled. I was like, why can't I do this? It is not easy.
And I really respect anyone who can do it. You both thrive on the office. It's amazing. Well, I wanted to say that. I think one of the reasons why the office was so successful is not just you would arguably be in the conversation for best ensemble cast on TV and mainstream TV, but there's so much heart that's unexpected.
I remember watching an interview with your editor, who said that as he was editing the scene where Jim and Pam are on the boat for the booze cruise, that he's editing. He goes, I knew what happened. And I was still there going, kiss her. Oh. Kiss her. Come on, Jim, kiss her.
You're working on the show. Yeah. You know what's going to happen, and you're still so invested that you're yelling at the screen to have the characters kiss. That's rare in any medium, but on television at the time, it was unheard of. So we were yelling at the screen, things like that.
Kiss her, and oh my god, and Jim can't come back from Stanford with her. Come on. And Pam's doing this when she walks across the hot coals. We were just invested in everything. And then on top of that, it was hysterical. So that was just an added bonus to the show. Was lightning in a bottle.
I mean, it's tough to get that again. I don't know if we ever will, frankly. I mean, I don't know if I ever will. It was a dream job. Yeah. Came around at the exact right time. And I felt like I was ready. My acting coach always says, successful
come when your readiness meets the opportunities. And so you can be as ready as you are and then never have an opportunity. But likewise, you can have all the opportunities in the world, which I was getting with all of my auditions for three camera shows. But I wasn't ready. And so the office for me was the thing where finally
the opportunity met the readiness. I think that's true for a lot of our cast too, because we had a lot of really great seasoned comedians that had just been, you know, plugging away. Kate Flannery is hilarious. She was part of a lounge act called the Lampshades. Oscar Nunez, I had met at the Groundlings. He was in Hot Towel. We had a scene together. You know, obviously, Steve Reign, everyone had been sort of putting their dues in, putting their time in,
and it was just that right moment. But I have a question for you guys. Yeah. So, OK, if you could play a character on The Office, like, which one would you want to play? Oh, that's such a good question. Will, I really hope you say Dwight. Yeah, we've got to be Dwight. Comedy does actually tend itself towards Dwight.
It does. You'd be Jim. Yeah. I'd be Dwight, and you'd be Pam. I'd want to be Pam. Yeah, I would have to agree with that assessment. Yeah. I would have to agree with that assessment entirely.
Now I really, really wish we had brought a Jim Pam Dwight scene with us. Yeah. We should do that next time. Which scene would you like? Yeah, which scene would you like? I next time. Which scene would you like? Yeah. We should do that. Oh, my god.
Which scene would you like? No, I mean, that's definitely how I would have cast it, too, if it had to be the three of us to do it. It would have been that. So great. Is it true that there was a chance you guys were going to be canceled after the first six? Oh.
Oh, yeah. Not just after the first six. The first six episodes any day when we went, we were like, oh, we're still here. Yay. That's crazy. And just after the first six. The first six episodes, any day when we went, we were like, oh, we're still here, yay. Oh, that's great. And we were not a hit. And also, NBC wasn't rallying behind us at all. No, we were very surprised to get a pickup for season two,
but the pickup for season two was only six episodes. Oh, my gosh. And then they ordered only six more. More, yeah. And then they ordered the back 12. And we ended up with 24 episodes. I mean, yeah. At the end of this six episodes, those first six,
they printed my name on paper and they just laminated it with some Velcro and that's what was on my door. So I took my laminated piece of paper home with me. Yeah. I'll save it forever. We just thought that was it. So what episode would you then look to and say, that's the one where we knew what we were doing.
Everybody knew we were going to go from here. We're now a hit. This is what's going to happen. It's very clear to me as far as like the downloads, because the Christmas episode with Yankee Swap and babies playing jazz poster and Phyllis is sad of admit all of that the teapot that episode became the number one download on iTunes Okay, and so the ratings weren't there the ratings were there But this new world of like oh wait we can make money off of this other thing this Downloadable item not the cast doesn't get money for that.
But people were watching it on their iPods, remember? And they were like, okay. Also for Yankee Swap. Yes, video iPod. Now, what about you guys? Did you always have, well, you mentioned individually you felt like you could be fired at any moment, but what about the show as a whole?
Yeah, we always felt like we were pretty much on the bubble. We never ever, maybe three to four or four to five, maybe one season we knew picked up for the next one. I think four and five maybe we were kind of, it was also just a weird position to be a kids show. We felt like nobody was watching, you know, like we had no cultural feedback. Like there was no online culture,
but there was also just no way that kids could, like we would get recognized, like, couldn't go to the mall. But otherwise, like as far as like the industry or we were nothing. We felt like we were getting no, you know, and so it's only now that we're like, oh, my God, we were big. Well, we also had one of our other executive puses on not not the one used to give us notes, but another one who just recently came on and said
that was also a network thing where they specifically didn't want you to know that you were popular so that they couldn't go and ask for more money to make the show. Right, they wanted us to feel like we were going to be there. So if you're always on the bubble, then you're lucky we're giving you this budget. So don't ask for any more because you barely got picked up. Where if we knew the show was, or they knew that the show was popular,
the executive producers go in and ask for the moon. So to stop that, they would kind of make us seem like we're just, we're lucky to be there. Don't forget you're lucky to be there. But also we were canceled in 2000 with what Don't forget you're lucky to be there. Also, we were canceled in 2000 with what, like a 25 share? Yeah, right. Exactly. Like, nowadays everybody would chill for that kind of audience.
But that was a big drop for us. So that was, I mean, it was like, oh my God, we're only getting a 25. Yeah, we're done. Did you feel like you got to wrap up the show? Yeah. Yeah. We got a nice, you know, we had a very nice hour long with the retrospective and where everybody moves. We really did get a chance to say goodbye. It wasn't like we were just done. And our final scene was so great.
It was a really nice final scene. And we were all like really crying. Actually, in the classroom. We didn't rehearse it throughout the week. We just read it at table read and then shot it once in front of the audience. And that was it. And so it's us saying goodbye to Bill Daniels as Mr. Feeny and all of us just real emotion,
Brian kind of talking to each other in character. Very emotional. Wow. I'm very thankful for that. And I don't think a lot of actors get that experience. It's just you're just done. You don't get any notice. Yeah, your character doesn't get closure.
You don't get closure as a group or as a crew. A lot of people just get canceled. You're just like, not but yeah, your character doesn't get closure. You don't get closure as a group or as a crew. Yeah, a lot of people just get canceled. You just like not next year, guys. You're like, oh, yeah. For me, moving into any other acting job after Boy Meets World was a shock. It was like, we're not all best friends. We're going to be together forever.
You know, like, oh, right. That is such a rare gift. Yeah. Well, I was going to say that I think that's something that our casts have in common, which is that, like Angela was saying, for a lot of the people in the office, this was really our first big job. And you're a very open vessel when it's your first big job.
And we all like learned together, we learned about parts of the industry together. Like none of us had ever done a junket. None of us had ever been to the up front. So to all the business stuff that goes behind the making of a show or the publicity or anything. And so we're really bonded, not just because of the show we were on, but because we kind of learned about the entertainment business together.
Satellite media tours. Yeah, get up at 4 a.m. and talk to 25 news stations. 25 radio stations. Yeah, that have a delay, but you can't see them. You just sit there like... You just sit there like nice and you'll see them. Yeah, exactly. I'm sorry, you go ahead.
And also, you guys must have been there for each other for just fame, like what that weird experience is like of like getting recognized and now everybody's talking. It's like a weird thing, you know, and we're so glad we had each other. Yeah, we have people come up and say this to us all the time, which is like, you look like an older version of that lady on the office.
Oh my God. And people who we are like, that's true. You are correct. I am the older version. Older version of the older version. The older version, yes. I know. What happened?
Hindsight being what it is, would you have done anything else with your characters or anything different with your characters if you could go back and do it again? You know what? Yes. I maybe would not have changed Pam's hair. Really?
I kind of thought to change the frizzy mullet. When she started dating Jim, I said, I think she's growing as a person. And I had this whole thing in my head, character wise, that she was going to go to art school, and she's with her love now. And so maybe she's going to do more than just let her hair air dry and put it in the clip.
Maybe she's just going to primp a little bit more. And then later, I became sort of sad that that sort of signature hairdo was gone. So you might see it in later seasons. I tried to bring it back. There you go. A tiny bit. But when I rewatched the show, I became somewhat sad
when Pam's hair changed. That's so funny. And I kind of wish that I had just let her be. You even make fun of it in one episode. Do I? Where you say, yeah, including this very old, frizzy-haired picture of me. Yes.
When they're doing the baked beans going all the way around. When you're putting the beans on people's pictures. What does a bean mean? Someone tell Kevin what a bean means. Yeah. And Greg didn't want me to change it. He really loved it. Like, I somehow wore him down.
Well, Mindy had already worn him down. Well, this is true. I mean. Because Kelly's transformation. Yeah. So by the time you wanted it, he was like, all right. Well, this is true. Kelly's transformation. Yeah. By the time you wanted it, he was like, all right. He was like, whatever.
Some of that was a little bit selfish because what would happen is after work, maybe there'd be an event or something we wanted to go to. And I didn't want to go to that event with frizzy Pam hair. And so I was like, if I could be halfway there, if you could just help me a little bit. Yeah, it would be a lot easier. That's part of the rewatch is like recognizing
how different the lived experience is. Like the lived experience as an actor is like, I want my hair to look like my hair. I don't care about the iconography of Pam, but now that you can go back and watch it, you're like, actually that iconography was pretty great. Yeah, 100%. You can see it more like the way your producer did, right?
Yeah. You can see the... With you, with your hair. Oh, all... Yeah, it's like, why? You know, and at the time... You said the same thing, yeah. Yes. It's like your lived experiences from really...
It's important. And as an actor, you know, but a good actor... But for us, it was also because of how we grew up on the set. It was a little bit of control. Oh, yeah. Like, if we could go and cut our hair, then we had a little bit of control. Yeah, yeah, exactly. It's a different thing. So... But I think, like, as an actor, it cut our hair now, for us it's full on trauma. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's a different thing. But I think as an actor, it is hard to recognize, you know? What about you, Anne? I wouldn't change anything. I really wouldn't. I just, um... Would you have worn your pantyhose? Never.
And I didn't. Don't you think, though, if you're being honest... I was just honest about Pam's hair. If you're being honest, and I want you all to weigh in, don't you think the character of Angela Martin would wear pantyhose? Yeah. Yes, of course.
Right, Angela? No, no, no, no. Although, I would have to say, wouldn't pantyhose really pick up cat hair? And probably get run by cats. That's yeah. That is true. Thank cats. That's yeah. That is true.
Thank you. You're right. Thank you. So maybe there's a character justification. Characterized. That was part of my character assessment. She would not spend all this extra money on pose that would just get stretched up.
You'd have to be like me today and have an extra pair in your purse in case it gets run. She also buys most of her clothes at stores where they sell large colonial American dolls. Gap kids is too flashy. Okay, this makes me want to ask you a question. What do fans ask you to sign? Is there a quote from each of your characters?
Because I know ones that I get asked that one. Of course. I have a cat phrase. I have something called a feeny call. So I get asked to sign that quite a bit. Is that Life's Tough, Get a Helmet or the Good Looking Guy theme song from the episode you watched? Right. I wondered if you had to sign that quite a bit. Is that Life's Tough, Get a Helmet, or the Good Looking Guy theme song from the episode you watched? Right, I wondered if you had to sing that,
because I know Craig Robinson, people ask him to sing. Out of paper, out of stock. Yes, yes, yes. So yeah, no, having a catchphrase, you have to write the same. Do I? No, I was thinking you don't really have one. I get asked to do Hello, Buh-bye, I'm so with have one. I get asked to do Hello, Bye-Bye, I'm So at the Mall.
Yes. I get asked, Topanga says something to Corey at one point where she says, you are you and I am I, and if in the end we end up together, it's beautiful. So I get that quote. People like us to write, dream, try, do good, even though we didn't say it. Use a mirror, babe.
Use a mirror, babe. Oh, use a mirror, babe. Use a mirror, babe. It was an episode where I walk, her first episode, she was very much a hippie. She draws with lipstick during a reciting a poem. And so I walk in and I look at her and just say, use a mirror, babe.
And that was a big laugh. But that's it. I don't really have catchphrases. That's interesting. There's a little bit of an office, boy meets world crossover connection. But Will, you might be the only person who has it, which is casting director Alison Jones.
Oh, she did our cast your pilot episode. She's a legendary casting director. Yeah, no, she wasn't on our show, and I don't even remember. I went back like five times. I don't remember her. I don't, you know. Oh, no.
Yeah, I know. It's too bad. So I mean, I'm sure I've met her, but yeah, I was too young to. Well, we have another connection from the episode that you actually had us watch is Hank, your security guard, played the coach on Boy Meets World. Oh, he's so fantastic.
And Matthews, B-team's doesn't get sued up for away games, is the one who plays Hank. That's amazing. You know, I hustled up the stairs. I love that scene so much when he's going between the coffee and the chair. He takes a little, like, jelly bean. That was an improv. He did a little, like, jelly bean.
That was an improv. He did that. And I laughed the first time he did it. That's so great. And then Steve as Michael is like, get out of here. I'm like, that's it. I can't help it. But also just when he sits in Pam's chair.
Oh my god. It just was really hard for me not to laugh. There was a few times we broke. One of the most, I would say really precarious moments of Ed breaking was his character has to take a bite of a tuna fish sandwich. Oh yeah. It's really a tuna fish sandwich.
And then I have to go and grab one and kiss him. Yeah, I thought of that while it was happening. Yes, and Ed right before the take said, Ange, I'm not going to open my mouth at all so you don't get any of this tuna. I said, thank you. The camera couldn't see his face right as I grab him. My body's blocking.
But he'd go like this. And he would hold, because he had to hold his breath, because I wanted it to be this like, and he started to break at one point. And I'm like, and he's like, frr, frr, frr. And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no. no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, This was great. This was amazing. So wonderful. Ryder, thank you for reaching out. Of course. Thank you for responding. And suggesting it. This was so cool. It was really great.
And it was really nice for us to be able to look you in the eyes and to thank you for paving the way for us to even have a show. And so we just, we admire you both so much. Admire what you do. Love your work, both podcast and TV. So thank you for everything. Well, thank you. Thank you. Well, I will be getting your phone number for future Office Ladies.
That's the problem. Hit me up. Well, let you know what happened on your show. OK, thank you. Thank you. Well, that was so much fun. They are so fun, lady. They really are. I'm so glad we did that. I'm so glad that Ryder suggested it.
Yeah. I love just hearing about their journey becoming podcasters and rewatching their show. Yeah. It was really cool. I loved it. Well, listen, everybody. Head over to Pod Meets World because we
did part one of this collaboration where Pod meets office ladies. We watched an episode of Boy Meets World and we talked all about it. Yes, we watched Hair Today, Goon Tomorrow, and neither of us had seen it. And we talked all about it and we learned a lot of behind the scenes details.
Yeah, they gave us a quiz too. And I mean. You won. I did well. Anyway. You did. All right, you guys, go listen to that and hope you have a great week. See you next week.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.